(upbeat music)
- Hey guys, it's Justine and welcome
to my Apple Watch Series six review.
I've been absolutely loving this of course
I absolutely love my Apple Watch.
So this is no exception.
To be completely honest with you,
The Apple Watch Series
six is not a huge upgrade.
If you already do have a Series five watch
this maybe isn't the watch for you
but if you do have something that is lower
than a four or three,
this will be a huge upgrade.
They also now have an Apple Watch SE,
which is a lower cost
and they do still have
the Apple Watch Series three as well.
So there are a bunch
of price range options
for the Apple Watch and
I cannot stress enough
how much I love this thing.
I've had almost every generation
since the Apple Watch was first introduced
and over the past three years,
there was a point where I really needed
to start taking my health seriously.
I wasn't working out,
I really was doing basically nothing.
I mean i was honestly doing
the bare minimum to survive (chuckles)
I know a lot of you guys
have probably seen a lot
of the stories of how the Apple Watch
has helped save people's lives.
And I think what is important is yes,
the Apple Watch is a catalyst for that
but knowing what your normal is,
like what is your blood pressure?
What is your normal heart rate?
The fact that now you
can take your O2 levels
and be able to test your
blood oxygen is really
really crucial.
And this is something that
I really never paid
attention to in the past.
These are all very important things
and the fact that you can have
that all right here on
your wrist is so amazing.
(upbeat intense music)
The Apple Watch and fitness
basically goes hand in hand
and I know I've talked about this so much,
but the Apple Watch has really
really helped me kind
of quantify my fitness.
And up until recently,
I never actually went in and looked
at the data and I could see,
a significant increase in my fitness
and also a significant
decrease in my fitness
when I stopped working out as much.
I have five or six years
of heart rate data,
that I can go back and track these trends
and be able to have that,
if I ever need to give that
to a doctor or anything of the sort.
The O2 sensor in this,
is just another added benefit
of being able to quantify
and track your health.
It also runs in the background
so it will periodically
be able to give you updates.
And I've actually been wearing this
for the past few days while I slept.
Oh, this is gonna be my first night
of sleep tracking with
the new Apple Watch Series six
it's 1230 right now am,
and I have to get up at five 30
to post a video at 6:00 am,
So, this first night of sleep tracking
is gonna be quite interesting.
This is also gonna be
my first time sleeping
with the new graded watch.
And now Siri thinks
that I'm trying to talk
to her because I raised two, no canceled.
The real question is,
what is my battery percentage right now?
The battery percentage is 51%.
So when I wake up,
I'm gonna charge it i think.
And then at some point I'm gonna work out
and then at some point I don't,
I don't know, stay tuned.
Oh, wrong way night night.
So I woke up, like five 45
I actually woke up before my alarm.
So it's asking me if I wanna turn it off
(murmurs)finally need to get out of bed.
I went to bed my watch was 51%.
So now 41% .
I'm gonna get up postmark review
and then go back to bed.
Okay, I'm going back to bed.
It is six 18 video was posted
and now I'm gonna sleep until, not sure.
Maybe like nine 30, maybe 10.
I don't know.
It's gonna be a surprise to me and you,
night night.
I gotta set my bedtime again.
I'm up.
It's nine 19.
I gotta charge this thing.
So my battery is at 31%,
last night I went to bed it was 51%.
So this is our current situation
We're at 31% and now
we're gonna charge it,
while I go eat some breakfast.
And then I dunno, carry on with my day.
So I've tracked the last one, two, three,
four nights of sleep.
This one is not good.
I went to sleep at 1239
and I woke up at 5:24 am,
That was the day that I was posting
my Apple Watch video at 6:00 am,
and I was trying to finish editing
it the night before.
I'm a very deep sleeper,
not much wakes me up at all.
So it was kind of cool to be able
to really see this data
right here, real time.
So since I do normally wake up at 6:00 am,
I'm gonna set this time for...
I would have to go to bed
at least by 10 to get eight hours.
So I'm gonna say, I wanna
be in bed by nine 30.
I'm so old (chuckles)
Here's some blood oxygen tracking.
Here's some data.
This is kind of cool because I can
see when I sort of had a lower range
which seems to be when I'm sleeping.
So this is the VO2 max data.
And this is what's kinda
fascinating because
I hadn't looked at this until recently.
So let's see, we're gonna
go back to March, 2018
which was two years ago.
The fact that I have
all of this data dating
back two years ago, is so cool.
VO2 max is the maximum amount
of oxygen your body can
consume during exercise.
So you basically want to
have a higher VO2 max.
This indicates a higher
level of cardio fitness
and endurance.
So March, 2018 not so good
May, 2018 I started working out again 44.6
and you can see the trend
slowly goes down here
from July to October back to 39.
Oh, struggle city,
August, 2019 to December
nothing too crazy.
But then sort of when the pandemic hit,
all of the fitness activities
that I used to do, I
couldn't do any longer.
Thankfully, I was
quarantined with a treadmill
so you can really see the increase here
from February to June.
So we went from 39.1 to 44.4
and then I was slacking
a little bit (chuckles)
And then recently I
started running a lot more.
So currently we're at 45.3.
I'm about to do my first
run with the Apple Watch
I, I also haven't charged it yet,
So I just woke up.
I woke up like a long time ago,
but (chuckles) my plan is I'm gonna run.
Hopefully the battery will stay charged.
We're at 15%.
I hope that'll be okay.
I should have charged
it before the workout
while I was doing actual
work in my computer,
but I didn't
So anyway, time to do the run
hopefully it'll last.
First run with the new Apple Watch.
(background noise)
Also good news, 6% battery
So I did make it through the run
and that's exciting.
(upbeat music)
So this is really cool
to be able to actually see a difference.
And you know ,
I think when you first start working out
you'll start to feel differently,
but to be able to have these numbers right
in front of you to actually validate all
of the work that you're putting into it,
is pretty awesome.
Another thing that I was also doing,
was tracking my foods
and I was tracking them very specifically
because I was trying to link
what foods actually made me feel better.
This was also a question that I got
on Twitter because I was talking about
how I can't track a lot
of the training that I do.
So in jujitsu, the last thing that
you should be doing is
wearing an Apple Watch.
You can hurt your training partner.
You can hurt yourself.
You could also break the watch
and this is not something
that you should ever wear.
You shouldn't wear jewelry,
you shouldn't wear anything.
So I was wondering,
this does have a martial
arts tracking on it?
So I got a question on Twitter asking
if I train with my Apple
Watch when I do jujitsu.
And the answer is, absolutely not.
You can hurt yourself.
You can hurt your training partner.
Like it's the last
thing that you should do
but there is a martial
arts workout on here.
So I feel like you could maybe use that
if you're doing solo
drills or if you have this.
Go sleep, go sleep, go sleep.
Wouldn't recommend that either
Cause you're still gonna
probably hurt yourself.
This was also a really bad
quarantine purchase but
- [Man] If you're watching,
tell us what this is.
- Oh, this is my training dummy (chuckles)
One of the biggest
questions that I've got,
when you guys see pictures
of my gym you're like,
what is that creepy thing in the corner?
This is a,this is a training dummy.
And you know what?
I thought this was gonna
be a really great idea,
that I could use this to train.
Since, you know quarantine
you can't train with a person.
I don't like it.
And I know you guys probably
don't either(chuckles)
So like it is okay if
you're doing solo drills
which I guess I was kind of using it for,
mostly just to do like, okay, you know
Some surfing, but like
it's like, it's not real.
This is not a real body.
Like, how am I gonna
try to pass your guard
Like this?
I just can't
It's, it's fine.
This thing also scares me in
the middle of the night.
Cause it's just sitting out here
and if I have to walk out here
to go to the bathroom,
I think it's a person.
Tell you one thing,
if you guys ever need to move Bobby
(upbeat music)
We're a couple of days into testing
the Apple Watch Series six
and my Apple Watch actually just
- I don't know how to respond to that.
(gentle bang on the table)
- This is the Graphite
Stainless Steel Case
with the Milanese Graphite Loop.
And this has actually already
been unboxed by my sister
but I really wanted to show you guys
how cool this looks.
Cause it is a beautiful, beautiful watch.
If you've already seen
the unboxing in my sister's.
Well, welcome to number two.
This looks really good, very shiny.
She did a very good job
packaging this backup
I will say that.
(package opens)
Here's the thing,
I love the Solo Loop so much
that I feel like I'll probably
never even wear this.
This would be like,
my fancy going out red carpet look
but I don't see myself ever
doing that ever again (chuckles)
What's cool now is you can pair
multiple Apple Watches in iOS 14.
So it's really nice because
if I do want to switch up,
I can just continue using both
of these and then pair them as needed.
But yeah, look at you
Oh, you're upside down
because you don't know me yet.
So over the past couple of days,
I have been sleeping with
this every single night
and it's been kind of interesting trying
to figure out when I should charge it.
So usually I will wake up,
then I will charge it as soon as I get up,
I will either eat
breakfast or do some email
and then it's ready to go
and then I'll start working out with it
and then I'll just continue on my day.
But the one thing that
has been really cool is,
it will give you an alert on your iPhone
when your Apple Watch is fully charged.
(upbeat music)
The coolest thing,
is the new bike directions in iOS 14
and paired with the Apple Watch.
It was amazing.
I took the whole way here.
I was able to just look at my watch
to get my directions
and I even tracked my bike ride
5.27 miles, 50 minutes.
They're still going.
(breathes heavily) It is so nice outside,
I love it.
(upbeat music)
Here we go, outdoor cycle,
hour, 26 minutes,
10.2 miles, average speed 7.1
I think we've to kind of split these
in half because the calories
of, of this ride,
because my bike is sort of pedal-assist
but I'm really hungry
and tired from all of my workouts today
for you guys for this review.
Like my legs (mumbling)
So it's been about two weeks
with the Apple Watch
and obviously it's no surprise.
You guys know I'm such a huge fan
of the Apple Watch and this one
of course is no exception.
So what have I been doing
for the past couple of weeks?
Well, I've been challenging some
of my friends to do
some fitness activities
and that's one of my most favorite things.
Being able to really see
what my friends are up
to and have that kind
of friendly competition
to go that extra few
steps to close your rings.
And I have to say,
that Marquez has beat me yet again
and most of the time it's because
I have not closed my stand goal,
and that makes me really sad.
I've been spending a lot
of time editing(chuckles)
The best part about it is now
I've actually been using
this to track my sleep.
My favorite part though,
about the sleep tracking is,
the gentle haptic feedback that I get
in the morning when my alarm goes off.
And I almost feel like
the past couple of weeks,
I have been waking up feeling much more
refreshed because you don't wake up
with this crazy loud alarm just blaring.
It's just like a gentle tap on your wrist,
I wake up, I like,
I hit snooze for a second,
and then I go back to
sleep for a few seconds
and then it's like,
"Hey, you're still sleeping."
And that's when I get up.
I think if you do have
an Apple Watch older
than the Series five or the Series four
that's where you're gonna
really see the difference.
You also see a difference
with the charging
all in all, I think the
most important thing
is being able to have these heart
tracking features just to be able
to get that consistent baseline of
what is your heart rate.
I think that's really one
of the most important things.
If you guys have any other questions
about this Apple Watch
or anything in general,
feel free to leave those
in the comments below.
I look forward to doing a follow-up video,
answering any of your questions
and talking more about
my love for the Apple Watch.
Maybe I'll come back and be so,
just strong that I will
just pick up this table
and throw it and you'll be like,
Wow, she's strong.
She works out with the
Apple Watch (chuckles)
not only when Apple fitness comes out.
Look out!
(upbeat music)